bienvenidos al debate de france 24 cada
semana santiago lópez recibe en su mesa
a personalidades para debatir un tema de
actualidad que es necesario de momento
es una respuesta es tratado políticos
especialistas periodistas artistas o
activistas se reúnen durante casi una
hora para exponer sus puntos de vista en
eeuu y creo que cambio plenamente el
concepto de las relaciones
internacionales todos los temas están
permitidos pero yo no voy a responder a
insultos y descalificación participé en
el debate a través de las redes sociales
con el hashtag el debate este 24
acompáñenme en el debate por france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]